[Musique]
les cas de grave de kobe 19 serait-il en
fait causée par une bactérie infectés
par le nouveau coronavirus c'est ce que
laisse entendre un article largement
relayé sur les réseaux sociaux un copier
coller de cet article est tiré d'un
média nommer israël magazine et partager
plus de douze mille fois sur facebook
laisse croire qu'une découverte majeure
effectuée par des chercheurs offrirait
un grand espoir de traitement à la
comédie 19
tout ça parce que de bactéries
intestinales appelées prevotella serait
en fait larmes secret du nouveau
coronavirus selon cette idée
une fois infecté par le strass cause de
cette bactérie déclencherait et je cite
lipper réaction immunitaire quitté labre
les poumons et tu le malade
fin de citation le plus souvent ces
malades seraient des personnes âgées
parce qu'elle serait porteuse de taux
plus élevé de cette bactérie
conclusion de cet article il suffirait
d'antibiotiques déjà connu pour enrayer
la coved 19
verdict un tour rapide de la question
nous permet de conclure que cette
hypothèse dans aucune base scientifique
premièrement le sera ce kof 2 n'est fait
pas des bactéries mais plutôt des
cellules humaines grâce à une protéine
appelée protéine est ce un fait confirmé
par un virologue et une professeur en
médecine consultez par mon collègue
nicolas de rosa autre élément qui cloche
dans cette publication
les équipes de chercheurs mentionné dans
l'article ne sont tout simplement pas
identifiées perd encore le rédacteur en
chef du magazine
à l'origine de cette fausse nouvelle dit
en entrevue être incapable d'en
retrouver la source
une recherche sur les bases de données
d'études médicales effectuées par le
quotidien libération démontre aussi
qu'aucune recherche associant kobe 19 et
bactéries du genre prevotella n'a encore
été publié dans une revue scientifique
tout ce qu'on a pu trouver au sujet de
la prévôté là sont des lettres de
recherche publiée par un chercheur du
nom de sandip chakraborty ces lettres de
recherches n'ont aucune valeur
scientifique et ne sont que spéculations
selon la professeur de médecine à
l'université mcgill
anne gatignol qui nous suggère de se
fier uniquement sur des recherches
publiées par des revues qui inclut un
processus indépendant de révision par
des pairs pour d'autres détails au sujet
de cette fosse découverte majeure
je vous suggère de consulter l'article
de mon collègue
collider rosa disponible sur notre site
web et dans notre groupe facebook
continue à nous écrire et n'oubliez pas
de regarder notre émission diffusée dès
samedi dimanche sur ici erdei salut
[Musique]